>>> THERE'S A NEW TREND EMERGING
OF PROMINENT CONSERVATIVES WHO
USED THEIR PLATFORM TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST COVID-19 VACCINES,
GETTING THE VIRUS AND DYING FROM
IT.
MARK BERN IRE RECENTLY ACCUSED
THE GOVERNMENT OF ACTING LIKE
NAZIS IN THEIR PUSH TO GET MORE
AMERICANS VACCINATED AND HE DIED
SATURDAY AFTER A THREE-WEEK
BATTLE WITH CORONAVIRUS.
HIS DEATH COMES AFTER PHIL
VALENTINE, ANOTHER CONSERVATIVE
RADIO HOST IN TENNESSEE AND
DICK, A RADIO HOST AND NEWSMAX
ANCHOR, DIED OF CORONAVIRUS
SCOFFING AT THE NEED FOR
VACCINES AND VOICING SKEPTICISM
OF HOW EFFECTIVE THEY ARE.
>>> JOINING US NOW IS CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR S.E. CUPP.
GIVEN THIS NEW TREND IN WHAT
WE'RE SEEING, IS THERE ANY
CHANCE IT COULD CHANGE MINDS?
BECAUSE WE'RE HEARING FROM PHIL
VALENTINE'S BROTHER SAYING, IF
HE COULD TELL YOU NOW TO GET IT,
HE WOULD.
>> LOOK, YOU HOPE SO.
I MEAN, THESE ARE ANECDOTAL
EXAMPLES, BUT YOU HOPE THEY ARE
JARRING ENOUGH.
I THINK THIS IS A BIGGER
PROBLEM, THOUGH, WITH RIGHT-WING
MEDIA.
YOU KNOW, YEARS AGO I WAS ASKED
TO FILL IN FOR A RIGHT-WING
RADIO HOST FOR A COUPLE DAYS.
I DID MY JOB.
I BROUGHT MY STRONG OPINIONS AND
PASSION AND FACTS AND WAS TOLD
AFTER, BY THE STATION OWNER,
THAT WAS GREAT BUT YOU AREN'T
OUTRAGED ENOUGH.
I THINK THE INDUSTRIAL OUTRAGE
THAT'S TAKEN OVER RIGHT-WING
MEDIA IS CORROSIVE.
OUTRAGE IS ALL THAT MATTERS.
ALL OF THESE GUYS YOU MENTIONED
REALLY, YOU KNOW, TOOK THEIR
CHARACTERS SERIOUSLY AND WORE
THEIR CHARACTERS NOT JUST ON THE
AIR, BUT WHEN THEY GOT HOME, TO
THE POINT THAT THEY REFUSED A
LIFESAVING VACCINE IN THE MIDST
OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
AND, LOOK, EVEN TRUMP WASN'T
THAT METHOD.
TRUMP GOT THE VACCINE EVENTUALLY
AND IS NOW GETTING BOOED AT HIS
OWN RALLIES FOR TELLING PEOPLE
TO GET IT.
BUT I THINK IF YOU'RE A VIEWER
OR A LISTENER AND YOU ARE PRONE
TO THESE ARGUMENTS, YOU ARE
GOING TO TAKE THESE RADIO GUYS
VERY SERIOUSLY WHEN REALLY ALL
THEY'RE DOING IS ACTING A PART.
>> IT'S A TRAGEDY FOR THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES, IT REALLY IS.
IT'S AN EVEN BIGGER TRAGEDY IF
PEOPLE LISTENED TO THEM.
>> YES, AND MANY DO.
>> AND THEN IT BEGS THE
QUESTION, OKAY, SO IF THE DEATHS
OF THESE PEOPLE, NOW ALL THEIR
FAMILIES SPEAKING OUT CAN'T
CHANGE MINDS, WHAT CAN?
I HEAR FROM SCIENTISTS IN THE
GOVERNMENT, GOVERNMENT
SCIENTISTS WHO SAY, IT'S HARD
FOR US BECAUSE WE SOMETIMES FEEL
WHEN WE START SPEAKING OUT ON
VACCINES, IT JUST BACKFIRES.
>> DEAF EARS.
>> IT'S TO LOOK AT THE DATA
HIRE.
THIS ISN'T THE THREE OF US
TALKING ABOUT THIS OUT OF
NOWHERE.
THE DATA IS VERY CLEAR, THE
LARGEST GROUP OF AMERICANS WHO
ARE UNLIKELY TO GET THE VACCINE
ARE WHITE REPUBLICANS.
WITHIN THAT GROUP, ONE OF THE
LARGEST GROUPS ARE REPUBLICANS
WHO WATCH RIGHT-WING NEWS.
THIS IS NOT MADE UP.
THIS IS A VERY REAL CORRELATION,
NOW CAUSE AND EFFECT.
AND YOU HAVE TO ASK, OKAY, THESE
THREE RADIO HOSTS HOPEFULLY WILL
DO THE JOB.
BUT THE DEATHS OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WORLDWIDE, NOT JUST THE
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS, DID NOT
DO THAT JOB.
SO YOU HAVE TO WONDER IF THESE
PEOPLE ARE REACHABLE.
YOU HOPE THEY ARE.
BUT I'M NOT SO SURE.
>> AND WE KEEP HEARING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, LISTEN TO YOUR
DOCTOR, TALK TO YOUR DOCTOR
ABOUT GETTING VACCINATED.
IN REALITY A LOT OF PEOPLE
LISTEN TO THIS.
THEY HAVE MORE INFLUENCE THAN AN
OUTSIDE CARE DOCTOR WOULD.
>> S.E., STAND BY, IF YOU WILL.
WE HAVE AN AUDIO PRESENTATION
WE'D LIKE YOU TO SEE.
>>> A COUPLE OF JUST LIES
SPREADING ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN
IN CERTAIN CIRCLES, CNN FACT
CHECKER DANIEL DALE HERE TO SET
THE RECORD STRAIGHT.
>> TWO REALLY WEIRD LITTLE LIES
ABOUT PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN WENT
VIRAL AMONG SOME CONSERVATIVES
ON TWITTER.
THE FIRST OF THESE LIES WAS THE
REMAINS OF THE U.S. TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN WAS RETURNED TO THE
MILITARY BASE AND NOBODY SHOWED
UP TO HONOR THEM.
THIS CLAIM WAS TWEETED AMONG
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES,
AMPLIFIED BY A FOX NEWS HOST
AMONG OTHERS.
IT WAS COMPLETE NONSENSE.
THESE TWEETS WERE TWEETED
SATURDAY NIGHT HOURS BEFORE THE
REMAINS OF THE TROOPS ACTUALLY
ARRIVED AT DOVER AIR FORCE BASE.
WHEN THEY DID LAND SHORTLY AFTER
8:00 A.M. ON SUNDAY, PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN, FIRST LADY JILL
BIDEN, SECRETARY OF STATE,
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE AND
NUMEROUS OTHER BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS WERE
THERE FOR THE DIGNIFIED
TRANSFER.
THE OTHER LIE WAS PRESIDENT
BIDEN FELL ASLEEP DURING A WHITE
HOUSE MEETING LAST WEEK WITH
ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER NAFTALI
BENNETT.
THIS SHOWS THE VIDEO DID NOT
HAPPEN.
THE VIDEO SHOWS PRESIDENT BIDEN
DID DROP HIS HEAD AND KEEP IT
THERE RIGHT AFTER PRIME MINISTER
BENNETT MADE REFERENCE TO THAT
WEEK'S DIFFICULT DAYS,
PRESUMABLY A REFERENCE TO WHAT
HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN.
BUT PRESIDENT BIDEN KEPT MOVING
HIS HANDS THE WHOLE TIME.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE WAS CLEARLY
AWAKE.
AND ONE OF THE VIRAL TWEETS CUT
OUT WAS PRESIDENT BIDEN
RESPONDED IMMEDIATELY AND
APPROPRIATELY RIGHT AFTER PRIME
MINISTER BENNETT STOPPED
TALKING.
TAKE A WATCH.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU NOW AND THE MANY YEARS
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
>> WELL, THANK YOU.
YOU GIVE ME CREDIT, MUCH OF
WHICH SHOULD GO TO BARACK OBAMA.
>> ONCE AGAIN, THIS WAS A WHOLE
BUNCH OF NONSENSE.
JOHN AND KAITLAN?
>> THERE IS LYING AND SPREADING
MISINFORMATION, AND THEN THERE
IS LYING AND SPREADING
MISINFORMATION ABOUT FALLEN
SOLDIERS WHILE THEIR PARENTS
HAVE JUST FOUND OUT IN THE HOURS
BEFORE THAT THEY HAVE DIED IN
ACTION.
>> YEAH, IT'S APPALLING.
BUT IT'S ALSO, I'M SAD TO SAY,
NOT SURPRISING.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO CONSEQUENCE
FOR LYING, WHETHER THAT'S AS A
PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT TRUMP,
ELECTED OFFICIALS, MEMBERS OF
THE RIGHT-WING MEDIA.
THERE ARE NO CONSEQUENCE.
THERE IS, IN FACT, SAFE HARBOR
FOR DOING SO, AND LOTS OF PEOPLE
WHO FIND CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
LIES TO BE MORE COMFORTING THAN
FACTS AND THE TRUTH.
SO I MEAN, THERE'S BLAME TO GO
AROUND, BUT IF YOU ARE PART OF
THE MEDIA -- AND I'M LOOKING AT
YOU, FOX NEWS AND YOU ARE NOT
FACT CHECKING, LAURA INGRAHAM,
YOU ARE NOT FACT CHECKING YOUR
ANCHORS AND HOSTS, YOU ARE THE
PROBLEM.
>> THEY COULDN'T EXIST.
I'M SORRY.
HOW COULD THEY EXIST AS A
NETWORK IF ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY
STARTED FACT CHECKING --
>> THEY STARTED DOING THAT,
DOING JOURNALISM.
I'M NOT SAYING THERE AREN'T
FOLKS AT FOX DOING GOO